so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles I just remembered as that
Wikipedia list it's a collection of
hundreds of articles about unusual
unexpected and unbelievable subjects no
matter what link you click it's bound to
be interesting for that reason every
week I'm going to click on a new link
and teach you a little bit more about
our amazing world with that let's find
this week's article mm-hmm-hmm so US
presidents are four times more likely to
be left-handed than the general public
on average about 10% of individuals are
left-handed
while 46% of American presidents since
1923 were left-handed why do we only
look at presidents since 1923 well
before recently left-handedness was
treated like a disease believe it or not
the Bible included tons of anti lefty
rhetoric so parents and teachers would
often punish kids for using their left
hand therefore most people including
presidents would often use their right
hand to write even if they were born a
lefty it's entirely possible that many
early presidents were left-handed but
it's just not known since by the time
they entered the public eye they were
already using the right hands for
everything Herbert Hoover was the first
president that we know was left-handed
and since his presidency
Truman Ford Reagan or senior Clinton and
Obama have been added to that not so
exclusive club so what's behind this
statistical anomaly well for one
Americans and other Westerners are more
likely be left handed than our brethren
in the eastern hemisphere there's a
continuing social pressure in many Asian
countries to use the right hand so many
left-handed children are taught to
switch there's no longer that pressure
in the US so about 12 percent of
Americans are left-handed men are also
slightly more likely to be left-handed
so since approximately 100 percent of
u.s. presidents have been male just
elevates the chance of a left-handed
president by a bit
but what most contributes this
phenomenon is that presents are
generally considered to be smart people
the average IQ of the general public is
about 100 while the average estimated IQ
of presence is around 130 it's really
hard to determine if left handedness is
linked to increased intelligence but
Mensa reports that 20% of its members
are left-handed
what is undisputable however is that
left-handed kids have to learn to adapt
to a world made for right-handed people
scissors can openers desks doors roads
and even the English writing system were
made for writing to people Michael
Peters a neuropsychologist at the
University of Gulf said that his
research has shown that this necessity
for adaptation leads to left-handed
individuals being slightly more
resistant to social pressures and gives
them an independent streak these are
traits that most agree are useful for
leaders Chris McManus of University
College London wrote in scientific
America that left-handers brains are
structured differently than
right-handers in ways that can allow
them to process language spatial
relations and emotions and more diverse
and potentially creative ways in the
past couple decades three of the five
general elections have been exclusively
between left-handed candidates so are
the candidates overwhelmingly left hand
in the 2016 election nope
in fact no remaining presidential
candidate is left-handed is this a sign
of what's to come well we'll just have
to wait and see I hope you enjoyed that
first video in this series make sure to
subscribe if you want more of this
series I'll be releasing videos every
week you can follow me on twitter at at
1-over pro for updates along the way
you